all right here we go is the story from
the AP Trump returns to New York to face
historic criminal charges so as I stated
in the opening of the show if Donald
Trump made the decision not to surrender
I think this country would get ripped
apart New York would be complaining he's
criminally wanted we want Florida return
them as with any criminal Florida Ronda
Sanders would be like I'm not getting
involved in this I'm not going to do it
the feds probably wouldn't move in but
Donald Trump I believe
cares about this country and so I think
he realizes what would happen if he does
defy this this indictment I also think
he sees a tremendous benefit as his
polling has skyrocketed as fundraising
has skyrocketed so he's saying you know
what I'll give you exactly what you want
and you will regret it so the latest
story is President Trump returned to New
York from his Florida State Monday to
face historic booking an arraignment on
hush money charges they say that but
it's 34 counts so it could be more
they say already months into a Third
campaign to reclaim the White House
Trump and his advisors seem to relish
the attention cable networks followed
his plane at airports in Florida and New
York with video from there I mean I view
this as a as a complete backlash a
complete backfiring for Democrats he's
raised he raised five million bucks 4
million bucks in a day 5 million over
two days he's his polling is up 30
points 33 points Ron DeSantis has
completely collapsed against him in the
GOP Primary Trump could not have asked
for something better to help his
campaign
except the fact he might go to jail
besides that it's great well here's a
question I have for you do you think
Democrat jurors in New York will acquit
Donald Trump no
no I mean so he's going to jail well no
not necessarily I mean first of all
there's a lot of
legal uncertainty here it could be a
judge could say this is a misdemeanor
not a felony it is a New York judge so
that might not happen there could be a
long process of jury selection 34 counts
can get reduced down to five or six
there's also sentencing right so I mean
God forbid Donald Trump actually gets
convicted but if that ends up happening
you have someone who's never been
convicted of a crime before so you could
pull you in front of the judge like hey
this is a should be a misdemeanor that
you call a felony the precedent New York
is saying that if you lob Molotov
cocktails at police cars you don't get
serious jail time we give 21 000 to BLM
rioters my client should get community
service which I think would be hilarious
to have Donald Trump do community
service but uh as kind of everyone would
love him right no I mean like go clean
up the Brooklyn Bridge it would be the
most watched live streams Palestine 20
20 years ago if someone like Donald
Trump was charged and convicted with a
misdemeanor and then the sentence was
going to be community service the lawyer
would say perhaps our client can make a
large contribution to various charities
in the community in lieu of community
service and they would say yes being
Donald Trump I don't think they would do
that and your point about BLM while
correct I don't think applies to people
in New York City no I'm just saying
there's a broader question legally I get
that the whole trend is relaxed on crime
and also but come on you can hear that
there's there's an equal protection
there's a 14th Amendment claim that can
be made good luck no I agree with you
I'm as cynical as you are too but at
some point you're going to run into some
backstop at that could slow at least
slow this down and especially and then
also Tim before you go to jail you get
an appeal and the appeal courts the
appellate courts are a lot saner than
all right the original the the original
criminal court so Trump is not allowed
to leave the state
okay that's that's a potential do you
think that's going to happen so I cannot
imagine a circumstance where New York
jurors I'll quit Donald Trump no I can't
imagine that I cannot imagine a
circumstance one just takes one yeah but
then it's just a mistrial and then it's
well then but so that we're dealing with
time right so they'll say I'm I I do not
I right now Donald Trump has gone to New
York voluntarily he's going to surrender
I'm glad he did
I don't believe there's a strong
probability a judge remands him into
custody because of the fear of what
would happen if they do but it would be
just they don't do that in New York
anymore but that did you hear we're
talking about Donald Trump but but
outside of that the political
ramifications I don't think it will
happen however I do think there's a
possibility the judge says Mr Trump
you own several high-end properties in
New York City where you can easily
reside do not leave the state
for the duration of this trial
he will not be able to campaign and
they're just going to say whether or not
you campaign for president is not our
fault you are being criminally charged
that would be that's a possibility right
and I got to be honest when it comes to
the molotov cocktail thing I even
envisioned a possibility where when
Trump's lawyer politely argues to the
judge New York City's laws are very
lacks in terms of crimes committed this
is not a violent offender and then if
they reference just recently two young
people were firebombing police vehicles
and were given an opportunity the judge
will say how dare you question the
motives of people challenging the the
white supremacy of this nation Donald
Trump is a white I would not be
surprised if you're more cynical than I
am did you see what it is a New York
City Justice I don't I'm just not as I'm
not as like forthright and just thinking
the whole legal system will collapse
here's why I think you might be wrong
Tim just to play Devil's Advocate is
that the room for error here is very
limited every comma is going to be
dissected by the legal Community here
people could get disbarred this is not
some sort of Fringe case in Ithaca New
York they everybody involved in this is
going to be examined on the Appellate
level they could lose their law license
there could be complaints filed against
them you might be right the whole system
might be so corroded and might be so
poisoned however I think that because of
the I think I think this is my
prediction that they're going to just
blink and just keep their head down and
act as if this is a regular crime and
not do anything too unusual and say this
is the law and we follow it and this is
precedent fine you can go out nobody
else jail 34 counts hold on that not
necessarily they're misdemeanors though
well they're yeah they're misdemeanors
one felony no 34 accounts doesn't mean
you go to jail by the way I mean it's
just you could have one action that you
have 34 different points for example you
could get charged for fraud and you make
34 phone calls and it's all on the U.S
attorney or on the charging documents of
the prosecutor to determine what how
many counts there are there are U.S
attorney's offices in America that are
well known they're notorious for 99
count indictments just to do it so why
so let's look at why would they indict
Donald Trump in the first place I I have
a theory as to why it's Revenge
for winning winning no it's more than
that it's revenge for stealing the
Kravitz center from them
we know this in the psychological
literature trauma is a very very
powerful thing these people were
traumatized and humiliated that night oh
yeah they thought that was going to be a
wedding ceremony think of it they wore
their best clothes they thought they
were glass ceiling yeah no literally for
people to understand this is Hillary
Clinton's party yes and it's a literal
glass ceiling
corrections I get all messed up Javits
thank you for correcting me yeah for a
second I was like wait what are you
talking about oh yeah it's Kravitz that
Kravitz is in Palm Beach so the Javits
Center and they thought they were going
to a wedding and they went to a funeral
and that that does massive psychological
damage and Trauma and they soar a Blood
Oath that night do not do not mistake
the pettiness in New York political
Elite I I was re-watching the debates
2016 Trump Hillary and when he's like
she's like you guys better be glad that
someone with Donald Trump's temperament
isn't in charge of the law in this
country he's like because you'd be in
jail and then he just looked at her and
they looked at each other and I'm like
that's why they're going after him it's
Petty it's pathological it's personal
and so Donald Trump psychologically
scorned these people and they said we're
gonna get you back and now they looked
when he's a rain tomorrow there will be
a population of New York that says it
took us seven years but you stole that
night from us and you might have got Amy
Coney Barrett you might have got Comey
Kavanaugh you might have got all these
different people on the Supreme Court
but now we got you but but that implies
this is the end of it I don't I don't I
don't believe no no well they have
additional charges I mean the doj as you
said the doj is now looking at
obstruction charges the secret service
is going to testify against them in DC
no it's not the end no no but if you
were talking about New York politics
we're talking about who is in Alvin
Bragg's ear the New York City Elite
primary Hillary Clinton that is very
Petty very personal very political this
is about revenge and there's there's
other games to be played here with Jack
Smith at the doj and the woman in Fulton
County because of the phone call Trump
made which was perfectly fine
so then there's another theory that
they're doing this to try to take Trump
off the chessboard
um I'm not as convinced of that one this
one just seems to be Revenge politics
perhaps but I just don't see a
circumstance where they can set this
this chain of events in motion and then
appease their constituents by backing
down
no I think that's right and therefore
the room for error is almost nothing and
when you overcharge and create a crime
with a quote exotic legal Theory as
Maggie Haberman said on television
you might let a lot of people down again
yeah the the legal system in America is
designed to allow people that are
overcharged that have good legal
representation to fight it now you might
be a cynical about New York as possible
I do not have faith in the in the
pattern of behavior we've seen in the
New York legal system but everything
will be examined every single charging
sentence and syllable is going to be
hyper critical so
there's a potential I imagine of this
going to an appeals court correct or
even being escalated to U.S appellate
federal courts Supreme Court potentially
Supreme Court I think I think there's a
decent
percentage chance that actually happens
but in the meantime
you I think we're going to see hyper
partisan politicized law enforcement and
Judiciary
because too much of what I see is the
what I refer to as the freedom faction
which consists of disaffected liberals
Libertarians conservatives believing
well there's rules and the rules say it
must be done this way and then it's like
dude they fire bombed a car and then got
let go no I'm not even making that
argument I'm just saying that there's a
lot of there's a plenty room for error
for these people that think that Trump
is 100 going to prison that a lot can go
wrong that this they're gonna oh they're
over charging they're creating a crime
that doesn't exist they're upgrading a
misdemeanor to a felony also Michael
Cohen is going to be your star witness I
mean the only way I see this going in
Trump's favor is if after conviction it
goes to an appellate court with a trump
appointed judge and that gives the
Democrats an out of his own appointee
just Freedom excuse himself yeah well
that that's their out to avoid going all
the way down yeah but it would be a
state a judge it wouldn't be a trump
appointed judge it wouldn't be that's
what I'm saying it would have to only be
if it goes to the federal level having
some kind of federal court intervening
how would it get to a federal level at
this point and also Federal prosecutors
had already declined to prosecute this
right I I
do not see a circumstance where New York
political establishment says we've
decided to let Trump go I just don't see
it I do not see a jury of New Yorkers
being I think you're right I don't
disagree with that but so this this ends
up with Trump facing sentencing
potentially potentially I just I'm not
I'm not saying it's certain there's a
lot that can go wrong
this is this is in for them I mean and
go right for those of us that believe in
I don't actually justice but how I mean
I could go to the list again right
they're over charging but so who's going
to intervene and say this is an
overcharge the Democrat D.A the Democrat
lawyers the Democratic population a
potentially a judge that doesn't want to
get disbarred or put in front of
discipline from who in New York State
Court this is interesting because you're
saying nobody is going to follow the
rules that exist no and you're in New
York that they're Democrat no New York
judge is sitting there thinking
well the the the Democratic
establishment that controls New York
state is going to disbar me they're
thinking I will be disappointed if I
don't put Trump well look there's
you might be right but considering how
insane these charges are and how
damaging they are this is far from a
we're assuming what the indictment is we
don't know exactly what's in it yet it's
far from a signed sealed and delivered
case right and here's the thing Trump's
going to try to stretch out the timeline
here and he will use it to his Advantage
every one of these local actors is now
going to be under a national Spotlight
and National examination I'll give you a
couple examples everybody now working in
the DA's office that's going to touch
this case their social media histories
will now be examined they're not going
to be comfortable with conservative
Freedom loving media shining a light on
them and if they're hey hold on
Kyle Rittenhouse
is largely free today because of free
media that was on the street and we
shined a light and we exposed them but
he was also in a uh it was a Wisconsin
court in Wisconsin but very strongly
conservative uh no not so much that's
not totally true I mean Wisconsin as a
Democrat Governor it's more sane than
New York I'll give you that for sure I
what I'm getting at though is I think
the New York political Community is
going to be shocked at how big of a deal
this is going to be how much their
failures are going to be put on
Spotlight and these people are over
charging and we know that yeah but that
only meant but then maybe it's so what
by the rules man I don't think they're
playing by the rules so why would they
care about overcharging because you're
going to find a couple people that still
have some shame
shame who do they fear
so you live in New York you're a judge
who lives in New York City you know what
you fear you fear Auntie for coming to
your home with bricks and Molotov
cocktails let me let me have a counter
argument if it's that signed sealed and
delivered why didn't Cyrus charge Trump
on these why brag
I don't know because it's not there's
not unanimity that this is a good idea
that's why well here's what this is a
risk if it was Cyrus would have done it
he was a way better prosecutor way
better respected way more kind of White
Collar Law Firm Alvin Bragg is like a
street Thug that has become obtained
ongoing after Trump correct one so and
now he's doing it but the fact that the
fact that other DA's passed on this case
shows that there's a risk element here
that favors Donald Trump or because they
didn't a new guy gets in who's
escalating things
oh well that that could be the case but
it's not as if Cyrus wanted to get him
in diet he would have loved nothing more
I mean the guy was a total Trump hater
he would have been the darling of the
New York City Elite but maybe this is
not so much about risk as it is
escalation maybe this is that's a
separate argument though right so is it
about Trump or is it about trying to
distract from the looming currency
collapse and banking crisis to incite
violence amongst the American right so
that they can clamp down on us and say
CCC these people can't handle Freedom
they can't handle Liberty we're going to
try to raise the temperature in the room
because the American currency is about
to collapse let me pull up the national
Democratic party wants this to happen or
do you think brag is doing this despite
them potentially not wanting it that's a
good question too I mean I I think they
may not want it to happen I think that
too they may be saying look how much
money he's making his his polling is
skyrocketing you need to chill out and
this dumb local level guy is being like
I'm winning thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time